لماذا تطلب اسرائيل في هذه المرحله اباتشي
ولماذا هذا الرفض الامريكي بالرغم من انها
من الدول الاساسيه في الدعم الرئيسي
واللام محدود بالاسلحه لاسرائيل
يعني حينما يكون الكيان الصهيوني وجيشه
اقوياء طلباتهم تلبى وتنفذ ولكن
حينما لا يقدم هذا الجيش وهذا الكيان
الخدمات المطلوبه منه لانه ثبت ضعفه في
الميدان انا بتقديري ستر طلباته وخاصه ان
هناك هناك خلافات بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبين اسرائيل ليس على انهم لا
يريدون قتل الفلسطينيين او تنفيذ برامج ضد
الفلسطينيين وانما على الاساليب التي يعني
جلبت لهم الخزي والعار امام العالم كلاهما
يريد قتل الفلسطيني ولكن كل له طريقته انا
اعتقد انه الاباتشي الان وهذه الطائرات
الجيش الاسرائيلي في امس الحاجه لها لانه
قتال القريب والاشتباك المباشر بين
المقاتلين الفلسطينيين والجنود
الاسرائيليين في الازقه وفي الشوارع
الضيقه وفي المناطق المبنيه بحاجه الى مثل
هذه هذا النوع من الطائرات ودعيني اختي
العزيزه ان نعلق بعض الشيء على ما ما
شاهدناه من من صور التي تحطم الروح
المعنويه عند الاسرائيلين بشكل عام تحليل
هذه الصور معك لواء واصف ولكن فقط اكمل لي
جزئيه ميزه مروحيه اباتشي م الي تقدمه
بشكل اضافي عما يستخدم من سلاح جو
اسرائيلي في هذه الحرب
اي اولا هذا الاباتشي هو سلاح اسناد اسناد
قريب وسريع ومباشر ويؤدي غزاره نيران
ويعطي الروح معنويه عند الجنود
الاسرائيليين حينما يشاهدون لانه في حال
الجندي الاسرائيلي التحم في المناطق
المبنيه والشوارع الضيقه مع ال مع
المقاومين الفلسطينيين هذا يفقده سلاح
المدفعيه البريه والبحريه ويفقده اسناد
سلاح الجو الطائرات الحربيه المقاتله لذلك
الاباتشي هي الافضل في هذه الحالات تقدم
له اسناد قريب غزاره
نيران من ناحيه معنويه يشاهدها فوق راسه
فبالتالي انا بتقديري تدني الروح المعنويه
عند الجندي الاسرائيلي وهي الاساس في هذه
المرحله في القتال هي التي تجعلهم يعتمدون
على هذا الصنت من السلاح طيب فيما يتعلق
بالفيديوهات التي شاهدناها وبثتها كتائب
القسام لعمليتها النوعيه عبوه لاصقه تي بي
جي قذايف هاون وكذلك قناصه كيف رايت اثر
هذه الاسلحه وهذا التكتيك المتبع من
المقاومه بالنظر لبساط هذه الاسلحه مقارنه
بما يملكه جيش
الاحتلال يعني الرساله الاولى وهي الاهم
انا بوجهه نظري هدوء هدوء الاعصاب
المعنويات العاليه عند المقاتلين
الفلسطينيين الذين يبثون رسائل للعالم كله
وهناك شعارات حينما يكتب
وترسل رساله تحمل الايمان الوعي الثوره
هذا ما
شاهدناه
والمقاتل يضرب بمدفع
الهاون هذا الهاون الذي يقدم اسناد قريب
للمقاومين الفلسطينيين ويعطي غزاره نيران
ويؤثر على الروح المعنويه للجنود
الاسرائيليين بشكل
مباشر
ثم اللغم لغم شواظ هذا اللغم المتفجر وزنه
25 غم يحمل المقاتل الفلسطيني ويركض فيه
باتجاه الدبابه مركاب وانا اعتقد هذه هديه
للرئيس بايدن وهديه للمصانع الامريكيه
التي تصنع دبابات الميركافا التي تكلف
مليارات الدولارات وياتي لغم لا يكلف 100
دولار ويفجرها انا اعتقد هذ هذه رسائل
يعني مهمه جدا ثم الاسلحه الفلسطينيه
الاسلحه الفلسطينيه من نوع تاندم من نوع
الياسين التي التي كانت تصيب اهدافها بدقه
وتفجر الاليات
والدبابات ثم المقاوم الفلسطيني الذي
يختار بين الشباك الذي عليه قماش او
الشباك الاخر انا بتقديري هذه دروس يعني
دروس
وعبر المدارس
العسكريه ستدرس في المستقبل بحيث انها
تحتاج الى مزيد من صفحات التفسير لكل حدث
من هذه الاحداث التي يقوم بها المقاتل
الفلسطيني في ظل ظروف معقده يعني حينما
نتحدث عن ميزان القوى لهذا المقاوم بسلاحه
المتواضع بامكانياته المتواضعه مواصفات
غير قياسيه بالمطلق يعني حتى الذخائر
الذخائر محموله في كيس في كيس هذا هذا
يعني بالعلم العسكري في نقطه مهمه يعني
لواء واصف التقنيات والتكتيكات يعني غير
موضوع الاسلحه البسيطه والمطوره محليا
التكتيكات ايضا والاساليب التي يتبعها
المقاتلون في المقاومه الفلسطينيه هي
تكتيكات كما ذكرت دقيقه جدا في وقت ان
نتحدث عن مجموعات تعمل بشكل فدائي بشكل
مقاومه شعبيه ليس لها ارتباط
بجيوش تدرب هؤلاء نعم
صحيح صحيح يعني كل ما يجري هو حرب ايرادات
حرب معنويات حرب فدائيه صحيح كما قلتي
استخدام نقط قوتك امام نقاط ضعف العدو
اي يعني لا لا يوجد لا يوجد اي قيود على
هذا المقاوم الفلسطيني في
استخدام السلاح او تحقيق الهدف المهم عنده
الهدف وهذا طبعا يحتاج الى جهد اولا تنسيق
وتعاون بين المقاومين الفلسطينيين اضافه
الى الشجاعه اضافه الى الروح المعنويه
والقتاليه مهارات ميدانيه عاليه استخدام
السلاح رغم تواضعه لكن يحتاج الى حسابات
دقيقه في ظل ظروف معقده ولقد مررنا في مثل
هذه الظروف ونعرف الصعوبات والتعقيدات
التي تواجه المقاتل الفلسطيني ولكن حقيقه
ما نشاهده هو اعجاز عسكري فاق كل كل
الامكانيات التي تدربنا عليها والتي
واجهناها في الميادين العسكريه يعني صحيح
ان ان هناك تجارب عند الجيش الاسرائيلي
خاض معارك كثيره ولكن اعتقد انه مثل هذه
المعارك لم يشاهدها وخاصه حينما نشاهد
الجنود الاسرائيليين كيف يتحدثون في اشرطه
الفيديو عن عن ما يشاهدوه في الميدان من
بساله وقدرات ومهارات ميدانيه عند
المقاومين الفلسطينيين انا اعتقد اختي
العزيزه الرساله الاعلاميه هي مثلها مثل
الطلقه مثل القذيفه مثل اللغم هي تؤثر هي
هي رساله لصاحب القرار ايضا لذلك نراهم
مختلفين يعني نتنياهو والعسكريين مختلفين
الكابينت في ما بينه مختلف لانهم يشاهدون
ان هذه الامكانيات لا يمكن لهم هزيمتها او
مواجهتها